what does this look like to you yeah
these are stepping stones right so I
didn't take this picture I just googled
stepping stones but the reason why I
like this picture and I want you to have
it in your mind if you want I'm not even
going to try I could draw a bad converse
you but I am NOT artistic enough to draw
this so I'm not gonna but you can
alright the reason I want you to have
this image in your mind okay is that in
maths we often learn something and we
use that kind of like a well as a
stepping stone to get to new knowledge
right every time you learn something new
you think oh where can this take me
right what can I do next that will help
me expand my understanding so I want you
to think have you got the image in your
mind now thinking are stepping stones I
want you to think about what we did on
Friday there were two particular skills
that we learnt under the heading of
index laws does anyone remember can
anyone tell me what one of this goes
Watts we used it in the review question
standing okay if we multiply and you
might even have this written in your
book right if you multiply two numbers
and this is really important their bases
can't just be anything right what's the
relationship between the bases they've
got to be the same as you saw in the
examples right they've got to be like
two and two or 95 and 95 you've got be
the same right if we multiply then what
did we do to the indices we yeah you add
them very good so this is what happens
when you multiply and then there was
like the flip side right what happens
when we not multiply but divine right
what was the index law that we
established yeah bravi okay what are we
going to subtract
yeah the first power index take away the
second one okay
now Louise did you have a question or
thought wow that's a great question
there's a fantastic question I like it
so much that I'm going to hit pause on
it because we're gonna come back to that
idea but actually I would love it and
maybe you wanna do this as well I'd love
you jot that question now I don't want
to forget that question I like it so
much I'm gonna say I'm gonna write it up
here just for myself because I don't
want to forget it and I have a memory
like a sieve and what
come back a bit later on okay now each
of these two ideas skills multiplication
and division we're going to use each one
as a stepping stone to some new
knowledge okay
so the first little subheading that I'd
love you to make under today's work
which I suppose you could call index
laws continued because we're going to
continue thinking about them the first
little subheading is what we're going to
call power of a power and if that
doesn't mean anything to you just yet
don't worry we're going to flame with a
theme that we write underneath so to
understand what this means right we know
what powers are like this a power of a
power looks something like this if I had
say two cubed I could raise this to
another power like there's already a
power there and then I could say for
example take a power of a power okay so
I know some of you immediately like I
know what to do with this okay
Before we jump to that I want us all to
think about if you do know the answer
why is the answer what it is okay so
here's what we're going to do do you
remember when we established this right
I actually made us all sort of write out
in longhand
do you remember I said hey what's this
what's it actually longhand for it's 2
times 2 times 2 which of course is equal
to 8 right but this is actually the
meaning of it ok sorry this is the
longhand this is the abbreviation okay
not in the same way you may be able to
jump to the answer immediately but
that's how you know what I'm interested
in I want to try and learn something
from this right what does this mean not
want it equal to what does it mean Marik
okay pause right there
what was I there you already stained to
get me to the air time and I want to
know what does this actually mean so
that I know why the answer is what it is
just hold it the way you pretend out
what do you what are you thinking
yeah okay so Louise is talking about
getting some things in brackets can
someone pick up from here would you want
to pick up from where Louise's going
[Music]
okay we got there right this is the
thing with inner brackets why did we do
it so many times because yeah that's
that's what that five means right it's
like one two three four five I can count
we can count fantastic okay Merak okay
you know what
we totally could say I know what that is
that's eight and then I could do this is
also ate and ate and ate and ate and ate
and that's fine but we're going to
notice something different about this
that makes it easier when we just leave
it as a two rather than isn't it as
you'll see in a second we're going to
use this as a stepping stone right we
know what to do when we're multiplying
things that all have the same base what
happens to the indices we just read it
right here yeah go ahead
yeah I'm gonna add the indices together
I've got 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3
can someone told me what we get when you
add 3 together 5 times 15 very good two
to the power of 15 now here's why I
didn't write it just as eight okay do
you see there's a relationship here what
are you seeing the ways right so have a
look here right you can see i've got the
two cubed and it's to the power of five
so just like we saw before if you got
another color this might be handy right
the 3 and the 5 they combined together
we don't add 3 plus 5 we yeah we
multiply right we times 3 times 5 gives
us 15 right so this is really 2 to the
power of 3 times 5 just make sense so
power and power right this is something
bigger than just multiplying things with
powers we're taking things with powers
and raising them to powers so that's why
it's called power of power how might we
write this in summary
for if we took some number which is
raised to a power and then we raised
that to another power right what would
the answer be we're gonna start with a
the base will still be a base but what
do we do with the past
yeah very good we nailed it when you are
raising a power to another power you
don't add the powers you don't subtract
you multiply the powers and this is why
right seeing it in longhand shows you
yeah it's like three plus three plus you
get to fifteen okay so this is what we
call we mean by a power of a pound you
can put a nice big box around them okay